bonjour christian d'agir bonjour aux
mondiaux le temps vous êtes membre de
l'opl organisation patriotique des
agriculteurs de martinique l opam qui
est une des composantes de cette
vingtaine d'organisations qui se
regroupent au sein de ce collectif zéro
pesticide 0 chlordécone
vous avez une ultime réunion hier c'est
déjà une satisfaction de voir un tel
rassemblement sur un thème aussi délicat
que celui du père déconne alors je ne
vais pas parler de satisfaction mais je
comprends que vous puissiez me poser la
question au niveau de la satisfaction
parce que vous faites c'est une
problématique qui devrait normalement
intéresser tous les martiniquais est
alors le 24 nous avons eu 500 personnes
dans la rue deux cents personnes ont
assisté au premier forum du 24 après la
marche et le 6 et le 7 au lamentin nous
avons eu également deux forums où il y
avait à peu près une centaine de
personnes et avec 4 4 ateliers là nous
sommes en train de préparer la grande
rencontre du 14
donc samedi 14 et je profite tout de
suite pour faire un appel à tous les
martiniquais
oui d'être prison le samedi 14 à 8
heures la maison des syndicats
ce sera une restitution de travaux que
vous avez effectués sur cette
problématique
ah oui ça sera une restitution donc à 8
heures il y aura restitution de tous ses
travaux et à 9h démarrage de la
manifestation à fort de france
c'était facile de faire venir toutes ces
organisations autour d'une même table
pour évoquer cette situation c'est une
prouesse
c'est une promesse parce que bon
chacun tire un petit peu la couverture à
soi
mais là l'intelligence a prévalu qui
fait que tout le monde s'est retrouvé
autour de cette vision dogmatique a pas
lieu de satisfaction ah oui oui mais
d'abord un niveau d'al aroui niant
satisfaction bon alors samedi prochain
au théâtre nokia tant qu'anti taxer ces
propositions je te la mets sont devant
les bars et la troupe dit non à ceux qui
taxent de travailler exactement alors
axe principal axe principal la c'est que
nous demander l'état nous demande elle
est à dix points responsabilités parce
que ça qu'a fait qu' il mettait comme
bruno pennies et aux grandes écoles zéro
pesticide la halle est allé nou ka palé
là il faut que les services régaliens de
l'état
8 comment s'est faite cavalli committee
café à les années 90 2000 c'est à dire
qu'il fait contrôler on est tout point
de votre kiné qui ni sans exception qui
fait kiffer contrôlant les cinq
exploitations et puis également qu'il
eut établi des bureaux de contrôles aux
ports et à l'aéroport alors que ça c'est
dans l'immédiat ça qu'ils permettent
encore finir rapidement face à sakai
permettre justement dileo pht produits
et ben le fait que ces producteurs qui
est contrôlé et bien c'est sûr et
certain que les occasions et c'est en
laisse et étalages là c'est essart et
permettent également ses agriculteurs
clca produits en les dts n 10 20
produits en toute quiétude et
consommateurs qu'il peut acheter
également en tout cas peut-être qu'on
l'ait août et aller là où tu vas
descendre la maison des syndicats et aux
souhaits leurs pattes alfred kubin
préfet matinik là qui dit y est que
l'état qui mettait tout les moyens à dos
projet zéro que la décolonisation la
bella que le portrait régional de
martinique et ses métiers où patricia
wiimote en saiem et manière disent oui à
ça parce que aux fêtes préfet a t il dit
ça bal parc naturel régional de la
martinique
maintenant les à savoir qu'ils maniaient
0 cour des comptes n'en au parc la haye
fait jamais trop pressé ses deux chiens
n'ont pas trop pressés parce que nous
savons que nous réfléchir rapidement
puis est l'art qui maniait tarif est
alors ils se moquent à supposer qu'elle
mettait tout ses moyens bas parc la lune
nous sert à nous comme on dit c'est
qu'il disait au chlordécone a
dans ses assiettes chaque moment là donc
c'est un ensemble mardi que la bourre
bulot qui sait d'autre qu'à penser
qu'ils s'ajoutent la pensée que pensez
vous de cette démarche label 0
chlordécone
portés par leur porte nature et de
martinique avec le soutien de l'état
avec l'appui de l'état alors la démarche
est une bonne démarche mettant comme
gelée du temps leur reste à savoir si ce
label zewo cas d'école pour les produits
du parc où il ya des agricultures au
parc qui sont labellisés haut niveau la
marque parc
donc si c'est ça effectivement mais un
label aujourd'hui où nous parlons là à
mettre en place à la marque dans l'état
où se trouve la martinique
je n'y crois pas trop dans la réalité ça
peut être à la limite qu'une petite
démarche complémentaire un tout petit
peu tout petits pas un premier pas oui
mais que quand je ne rejette pas qui est
bon mais il faut voir la réalité la
réalité c'est quoi si on ne sait pas
exactement quelle est la cartographie
des terres plus ou moins pollué de
martinique
on ne sait pas comment sont faits ces
mesures ne s'est pas comment sont faits
ces analyses c'est déjà ça premier pas à
franchir
ah mais ça c'est un grand pas à franchir
et c'est très bien de me poser de
questions là parce que il y à une
cartographie il faut pas dire
effectivement vous avez raison il ya une
cartographie mais elle est globale nous
leur demandons aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
ya une chorégraphie précise pas ce que
je vais prendre deux trois exemples
rapide par exemple rivière pilote de la
cartographie qu'il devait piloter en
rouge mais cela ne veut pas dire que
toutes les terres de river pilote soit
soit contaminé le l'aurait tout le
laurier temps où je ne savais pas dire
également que toutes les terres holloway
sont pas terminés donc ce qui fait que
c'est et des exemples comme ça je peux
en citer plusieurs boxes ce qui veut
dire que ce que nous disons c'est qu'il
ya une cartographie avec les moyens
modernes que nous avons aujourd'hui de
pouvoir dire que telle parcelle et qu'on
termine et héros de parcelle n'est pas
contaminé mais moi en tant que
consommateur les marquages one animation
très sympathique très jolie khadim
iphone acheté poggi - parce que il
m'associe à d'autres équipes à polluer
qui bannit à y installer un mac à ferney
et puis à montrer moins bonnes qui sacre
à prouver mais que produit produit la
fin et b très bonne direction et c'est
une réalité alors justement rien ne
prouve cela donc ce qui fait que avec
les contrôles comme nous demandons
qu'ils doivent qui doivent se faire à
recommencer à se faire eh bien le la
marchande 10 ans justement cela est bien
une garantie à ce niveau là pourquoi
parce que la marché noir a été contrôlé
je vais vous donner un exemple encore là
dessus effectivement on demande aux gens
de présenter un certificat comme quoique
bombe effectivement la terre a été
contrôlée mais il y a yap les deux pieds
de vie ces deux failles dedans oui vu
qu'il n'y a pas de contrôle comme ça se
faisait aux années 80 aux années 2000
c'est à dire que la personne peut avoir
un certificat conquois que ça t1 a été
n'est pas contaminée et puis prendre un
produit vendre nos produits d'une autre
personne et présenter son certificat
parce que dans les années quatre-vingt
quatre sujets les deux groupes
contrôlent dans les années 2000 les
tenir revers imminente si je t'ai 15 déc
agricole monte parce que t'es trop
contre la présence à un panier à ces
deux kamikazes étaient montées
alors oui c'est vrai qu'il n'y en partie
dans le monde syndical agricole qui
travaille au royaume uni mais au fond
quelque part les parties comprennent à
rien même pas seulement parce qu'elle
fait partie des partitas là parce que je
mens tu joues dit que garantis a garanti
a dit quelle que soit sa vocation qu'à
passer justement pas en contrôle et
contre la cie les services quel gardien
de l'état c'est ça et mac a manqué mardi
les ans les saints et même fonds robin
mmm ont eu l'occasion d'y dit ça en
certains vendredis l'actif un grand
rassemblement mandico jojo dia les
services de l'état en martinique qui
aura fonctionné sous les cocotiers au
des années 80 à 2000 manqué six années
ça c'est pas un invention café ses
services tarifés sont des fois des
protection des végétaux noter qu'un
travail aux tigres à contrôler tout
point de votre critique à exister
il était comme monteur les exploitations
y est parfait contrôle également de
cette notation
et puis tu es ni deux postes au procès
rio pour imposer au pont donc
s'acquitter qu'à rentrer et puis sortie
des contrôles et donc nous tp fonctionné
puis on garantit donc 0 contre d'école
non épuisé au président laïc à passer
par ces contrôles dans la christian
d'agir le mot kaffrine adam en feu rouge
et puis métronome ma cabine epoté
besoins en sachet piment doux à saché
gobbo bas et moyens l'eau des puits man
4 nages en main qui me fait penser au
coût de hassen ou pas ben voilà
justement réclamé 200 contrôles et
d'échappement non non alors magas oui
parce que la question très pertinente
mais le fait que nous par ip mais t es
pièce côté 1 dans quel pays du monde où
baby météo mundele chapman
mais la facture il nie des contrôles qui
a fait une manière régulier et eboutou
pas tous bons ces mouvements qu'elle
fasse attention parce que parce qu'elles
savent à qui bon moment et aucun
contrôle et et les aucun contrôle et ses
moulins parce que la suite la cave il
n'y pas dès lors qu'un contenu semoun en
simulant qu'avant d'un produit
kiki malsain pour la santé est bon qu à
pénaliser lourdement et aux cadres
annoncée sable annoncé manqué de
dénoncer ça et là ça caille facile ou de
l'ambiance que des années 80 à 2000 ces
moulins des cafés attention wi lan cap à
l'est de produits de traçabilité du
produit mais en termes de dépollution
des sols qui ça nous plaît qui sera la
techni'ka permettent nos jeudi a de fait
pour nettoyer tic tac la terre la
surface de la terre entre deux
centimètres de la surface date ayant
pour certaines plantations qui ça nous
fait alors en termes de dépollution faut
nous savent que ça qu'avec elle on a peu
de temps parce que là toujours même
barella fallu dix ans a ajouté qu'elle
écrit que l'état qu'à foot c'est pas mal
de tête oui voilà exactement parce que
cuba qui tous pouvaient nous qui dans
l'archipel des antilles dont cuba ni
dépossède de décontamination faut nous
sommes ça et ensuite une idée ini des
organismes de recherche privé qui
mettaient en place des molécules qui a
lutté contre molécule chlordécone ans et
puis d'autres molécules et quitte à
aller encore plus vite qui
décontamination végétal ados qui
s'abritent a continué dit qu'on ne
polluez pas de relever en irlande est
l'un des centaines et des centaines de
manille alors que moi parce que par une
poignée en groupes puissants qui capa et
ricky capable à l'égard des cubes et
puis ramène à issia alors savez que
c'est des contaminations cas varier
entre 400 et puis 600 ans mais plus
auquel peu de temps pour mettez en place
puis nous qui avait été condamné bon
enfin vous puissiez en appui et puis uni
anti souilhe vous dis moi ça il sera en
prise de conscience nous ni martinique
les auteurs vingtaine d'organisations à
présent oui montagne on est organisés
crottes
alors nous on fait un d'organisation
pour les wc conscience et en maintenant
parce que photoshop et nous savent que
après la 14 ou la caf en appel de six
mois mais la viny tonnes et puis et puis
manifester en masse parce que plus nous
kaino goût aussi pour manifester plus au
garde à vous eh bien nous qu'elle peut
justement après ça nous qu'elle nie
d'autres mouvements pour qu'il fait on
est toute la martinique où il veut
justement à boucle infinie
au delà de la pression de la
manifestation de toutes ces qualités bat
greta et script aliments est très
diplomatiquement très gentiment
halliwell et gros groupe réunit les
moyens financiers peut être de investir
dans des méthodes cubaine par exemple de
dépollution des sols
alors si vous posez vos questions dès
qu'elles sont même une raison mais
qu'ils seraient entendus par les gangs
ou moi parce que c'est mon ami ni
l'agent ici hein alors faut que nous
savent que c'est monokini la jeune fille
à papa sicilia qui a eu ses moules en
ligne qui n'est qu'une légende en les
gones à faire c'est bien t'as pas trop
tellement qu'à 15 intéressés ont donc
moins bon qu'à penser que faut que à la
suite de tout ça que nous avons plus que
nous et puis que effectivement nous
organiser à mon mental ah ouais j'ai sa
part ou non pourquoi pas à lady
politique à mon mental à après tout ça
donc highways et politiques nous et puis
mondeo justement accompagnez-nous
investi caillot pour les wade en
politique qui peut donner sauf que ni
poèmes taki packagée bouger au loup
alors que dans une ou deux questions
écrites ou orales au gouvernement à lens
à normale sup athlètes des bouger parce
que normalement chaque corps de métier
ni en chambres consulaires et comme à
niveau dans la chambre consulaire la
pâte et j'aimais bien clé et puis quand
on prie donne n'a pas j'aime imposition
décoré en manière très forte et
déterminée
justement niveau dans la donc quelque
part ça normal qu'ils politique l'a
lui-même paris fait en lieu et place de
politiques l'aï là pour accompagner
donc il faut qu un niveau tu as là il
n'y en élément très fort pour ça
d'ailleurs que les gonades du parc
naturel régional la commune pac a
critiqué normalement c'est la chambre
consulaire a quitté pour balancer les
bras parce que la politique agricole
viennent à la chaume merci d'avoir été
ce matin avec nos questions de chirac
elle vous êtes membre de l'aubaine et
composantes de ce collectif zéro
pesticide chlordécone merci d'avoir tué
vendredi samedi ou lundi au samedi
rendez vous le 14 merci
[Musique]